you've dropped in you've survived the
sectors and now it's time for the final
stretch
and before we jump in keep in mind that
this upcoming weekend
is going to be a double xp weekend from
september 17th
to the 20th so if you're looking for a
quick way to
level up your battle pass this weekend
is gonna be it today we're being joined
by macro
to learn about clutching out that win
and getting some of those
late game strategies you might know him
from his twitch streams at the macro
show or his four noob series
on youtube but he also participated in
the most recent twitch rifles hyperscape
tournament
so let's go ahead and get to it welcome
to the pod
all right first things first macro
you've been playing this game all the
way from the open beta and watching it
evolve there is a brand new patch that's
been
changing a lot of what we've seen from
the game so far so
from your point of view how is it
shaking up the meta and what do you
think about the patch notes
the biggest changes that i have seen
have been with the hex fire and the
right one two guns that on
both console and on pc have kind of
taken over
on console the hex fire in general is
just dominating we're talking
because of the aim assist the hex fire
just felt so destructive
for console players and so luckily
they've decided to reduce the clip size
all around and reduce the overall aim
assist
just for that specific gun that alone
should help console players out a lot
then we move over all the way to the
right one for example the riot one
has been seeing a lot of play at the
highest level but the right one since
it's essentially like a desert eagle
it's a it's a
one shot you get four headshots you kill
them
so they just they reduced its overall
damage a little bit but enough where
it's gonna be noticeable
the protocol five has always been a very
contentious gun it's a sniper
and there was really no counter play to
it so they decided to add a little bit
of counter play with the lens flare
so normally you couldn't know now
there's a little bit of counter play to
it and they also added a damage falloff
after 150 meters
one of the bigger changes to the game
has to be with the way that the crown
has been adjusted
before all you had to do was hold the
crown for 45 seconds
and then you'd win and there was already
a crown barrier cooldown penalty
that was i think 150 but now
that penalty is 300 meaning that if you
have the crown
it's gonna take a lot longer for those
cooldowns to come back
on top of that the crown bears outline
is now bright yellow so before if you're
losing track of the crown bearer
accidentally killing his teammates
instead of the crown bearer that's not
gonna happen anymore
it's quite obvious that they're the
crown bearer now so we're gonna see a
lot less crown bear wins
especially because the crown victory
timer is no longer 45 seconds it's 60
seconds that is another 15 whole seconds
that we have to worry about
and when it comes to hyperscape you
might think you know all about it
because
it's another battle royale but there are
more than one ways
to win so macro can you tell us a little
bit about these multiple waves although
we did touch
a bit on the crown aspect but it's a lot
deeper than that isn't it
this game is a very fun battle royale
because i do appreciate that the way you
win
is a lot different so obviously if you
end up eliminating everybody
that's one way to win but the other way
is the crown mechanic
where towards the end when the when the
decay has finally stopped happening
a crown will appear in the middle of the
field and then an enemy can pick it up
but then it becomes this game of
protect the president almost where
essentially whoever the crown bearer is
your teammates or if you're playing solo
you just had to
survive on your own so you can still use
your guns you can still use your
abilities
your abilities have a lot longer of a
cooldown but if you can survive for a
whole minute straight with that crown
you can win the thing that i do like
about the crown is that it does force
people to fight you can't just camp your
way to
victory people will get out of their
hiding spots to chase that crown person
so there's never
a dull moment at the end so let's dive a
little bit deeper
into the crown aspect because you
touched on it a little bit holding down
the crown
is important defending your teammates
but also countering
can be really important too so let's
start off with loadouts or combinations
that you think are optimal
for holding the crown first so obviously
when you're holding the crown there's
two ways you can really play it towards
the end
you can either camp in a building in
that scenario you'd want to run
close range very strong in buildings
weapons and then when it comes to hacks
if you're going to be holding in a
building or just running away
either way i think invincibility is one
of the strongest abilities
when you're using the crown and if
you're just trying to hold the building
mines
can be really strong if you're just
trying to run away then
still i think invincibility is very
strong and teleport even slam any
mobility ability
is very important just to keep running
and running uh in that scenario you're
gonna want guns that are still pretty
good in close range the mammoth
uh the harpy but not grenade launchers
in that scenario if you're trying to
counter somebody that has the crown
they actually added a new hack during
season one and that was the magnet
the magnet is amazing for stopping
people from running away there's many
times where i just keep chasing down
somebody even if they have invincibility
activated
if i just pull out a magnet it pulls
them right to that magnet and you can
just stop them in their tracks
big tip big tip and it should be pretty
obvious don't use invisibility when
you're the crown bearer they can see you
regardless if you go invisible so don't
do that
all right so we get the gist of the
crown but there's a ton of other late
game tactics
that are really really important like
camping revive points or
making sure your team stays alive until
the end
but from your point of view macro can
you give us some
pointers on kind of staying ahead when
you get to the late game
and not giving up your ground yeah so
when you get to the late game
your team should be running assortments
of things right the way that i like to
play with my teammates and stuff is that
one of us has to run heels
everyone has to have mobility abilities
because you have to
you have to keep up with the crown
bearer when it does occur my biggest
recommendation
is if you're going to go for the crown
you have to let your team know you're
going to do that because it it's going
to put
it's going to make a lot of the
situations a 2v3 scenario because
obviously you can still fight but you
can't do as much
mobile things with your team so you have
to let your team know i'm grabbing this
crown if you're just grabbing it
willy-nilly without letting your team
know and they're not protecting you
and they're not with you you're gonna
die in the late game and it's gonna be
very difficult to revive because
at the end there's not that many respawn
beacons usually if you're alone in late
game if you can get a pick off with a
sniper or just from a distance and just
quickly
respawn your teammate as soon as you
have that opening you gotta do it
obviously people can camp that but the
moment you get one or two kills you can
get your whole squad back instantly if
there's only one squad left and they
already have the crown
it's actually a little bit easy to
revive your teammates because they're
not going to be focusing on killing you
they're going to be focusing on just
winning
so in that scenario go for the revive
it's not smart to try and kill
an entire team that has a crown by
yourself just get your team up
if you can and if you are going for the
crown obviously coordinate that with
your team
you're going to have to decide who's
going to be the best crown bearer and
you're going to want to swap their
abilities to make sure that they have
the best abilities so that's probably
the only time i would recommend swapping
abilities
either with your teammates to make it
easier or if you find them on the floor
if you find like a
armor or a teleport swapping that late
game that's probably the only time i
would recommend that otherwise
keep those gold level high tier
abilities and just try to win it by
killing
as always we love to end off these
episodes with some community clips
because you guys have been totally
crushing it
and watching all of your clips has been
super hype and we wanted to share that
with you macro so
let's go ahead and roll it
so got him slamming down and trying okay
he's getting shot he's about to die he's
about to die
oh right there he just baits him did you
teleport away to take the jump pad away
that is such a big brain play oh my gosh
like pretending like he
he pretended that he was about to take
the jump pad and it baited the person to
take the jet pack that gives you
the jump pad puts you in this like free
fall state where you're stuck in the air
until you
unless you have teleport to come back
down uh there's no way to really get
down quickly
so that's the perfect way to get out of
that fight that's really cool
okay so here he goes
teleporting away okay still fighting and
he's just
on the tree i didn't know you could be
on the tree that's actually news to me i
never fought on this side of the map
that often i guess
is he did he lose track of him oh okay
okay there we go not bad he actually
lost track
he actually lost track of him get that
kill come on just mail it just mail him
it's cool
that works too headshots do work nice
yeah i didn't even know you could be on
that street for that long uh it's really
cool you can
in this game because there's so many
different hacks like invisibility
teleport where you can genuinely just
lose track of people it felt like right
there either
either the enemy just gave up on
fighting him or lost track either way
that was really cool little escape
maneuver that that uh
that alex did over here was really cool
this game is so mobile okay so they're
just fighting in the air
they're he jumps in the air with the
slam okay wow that was cool
yeah teleporting down is just something
that i think is always a good play
if you're in the middle of a fight it's
just it's just having your
having the enemy player lose track of
you in any way is just
it's just smart spawn so i have to just
pick up whatever guns i think it shows
comodo because we're going to stay
indoors and then i actually dropped the
teleport and gave it to cam because cam
had the crown
and i think he only had uh slam magnet
and magnet is just not useful
at all if you're the crown barrier
obviously we're using it to great effect
killing
killing off different players trying to
chase cam down and i'm using
both the mammoth and komodo so it's a
really good
strong gun combination indoors and
that's what we're doing here we're
showing it off i chased this guy down
because i got him pretty weak
oh yeah this is we're just everyone
that's coming into us
they're not they're trying to kill us
but we're ending up killing everyone
else that's coming to us
this guy right here just tried to jump
through the window forces cam to escape
and then i was able to pull this guy
away from cam with the magnet
and we got the w and if cam didn't have
both teleport and slam there i don't
think he could have got away
that easily because he teleported and
then he slammed the biggest play there
was that i uh cam has the crown but he
needed something a little bit more
mobile
and i think at the time all he had was
slam magnet and that is just not you
don't need magnet at all when you are
when you're the crown bearer so we
decided to do a quick swap because i had
both slam and teleport i don't need both
of those
especially late game and cam needed
teleport because teleport
slam was him being more mobile was a
better player in case he had to run away
which he did at the end
all right that's all for our show today
but thank you so much for joining
us macro it was super awesome getting
your insight on some late game tactics
and just
hanging out are there any final words
you have for us
just play hyperscape it's free to play
if you haven't tried it
i personally think it's one of the most
fast paced most
aggressive battle royales out there it's
a lot different than the other
competitors that they have
so yeah if you haven't tried it why not
it's free
exactly guys why not it's free to play
now on xbox one
pc and ps4 and there's a lot of new
content on the way the new half runner
mode is back
and it's where you get your hacks
randomized every two minutes so
if you want to try out some hacks well
this is a good chance to do it but
there's only a few days left so
don't miss out don't forget about double
xp weekend coming up on september 17th
through the 20th it's gonna be the
perfect way for you to level up your
battle pass quickly but of course last
but certainly not least we do have
another
shard hint for you
[Applause]
[Music]
you